these otherworldly masks and monsters
along with thousands and thousands of
others were made by this man a master of
monster masks and creator of countless
creatures you know seriously look at his
IMDb
[Music]
you'll notice it looks a little big
welcome to my studio this is where I do
my job of Designing creatures for movies
and television and video games
all right can you draw something on the
Fly for us I probably could yeah all
right Draw Something aquatic ancient and
a hunter
I would say that the first step is just
start laying down geometric shapes and
the large forms to try to get the look
you're after
some gills
what I like to do is sketch it out and
then get more definition there are
pencils and then their inks so the
pencils establish the rough layout and
then inking is where you really Define
the specificity of your look
I don't know if this necessarily
captures exactly what was described it's
a fish man I don't know if it gets
across Hunter it certainly looks mean
and what's his name I don't know it
looks like a Dave to me Dave's kind of a
jerk he's not really a monster but he's
a monster of a person
I think monsters represent a powerful
being but it's something that is
concrete and can be dealt with very
directly David slays Goliath King Kong
falls off a very tall building these
dangerous bad things can just be dealt
with and they're gone and it's over and
that's kind of a fantasy because rooting
out evil in real life is much more
complex and much more difficult than
that
putting down his pencil and Pen Jordan
picks up a new set of tools to sculpt
mold and paint his designs from the page
into a three-dimensional mask in order
to start the sculpting process I take
water-based clay
and I just start building up a face
shape and I'm just going to do this out
of my imagination for expediency so
I'm just sort of establishing some
unusual features and to be honest I
don't exactly know where it's going to
go you know as a matter of fact it might
change great deal as I go I use an
enormous amount of clay every month I
probably order several hundred pounds
one of the things about creating is that
you do get into kind of a Zen mode
time goes by and you don't even realize
how much time is passing the act of
creating is so pleasurable I mean it's
addicting it really is
so I'm putting I forms in which are just
spheres plastic spheres that establish
the shape of the eyeball that once we
mold it will make a nice clean shape in
there because the plaster will record
the nice clean shape of the sphere
but what we're always going for is what
is going to bring us the most character
what is going to affect the viewer the
most
if it's adding teeth it's adding teeth
if it's giving the eyes a more Sinister
feel if it's scrapping it and starting
over the whole point is to bring out the
most and the best character you can so
it's not necessarily going to look
exactly like this but almost all of this
is just by way of establishing the kind
of feel I want I know I want these horns
to be full of intricate detail I've
added these sort of braided looks to
them and eventually I want them to kind
of feel almost like tree branches or
gnarled Roots so everything I've done is
very deliberate in the sense that it
takes my character to where I think it
should go
Jordan's Love Of Monsters has been a
central part of his imagination since
his childhood I grew up in the 1970s and
the early 80s and latex masks were
becoming actually a very competitive art
form I wanted to know how these things
were made from very early age so when I
was 14 or so I started trying to figure
out how to make latex masks on my own I
got little Snippets of information from
magazines like fangoria and Cinemagic
and I started to kind of get a general
idea the first really professional mask
I ever did was a very simple demon mask
that I did when I was about 17. it had a
slick finish to it that I just hadn't
achieved before eventually I got offers
from Mass companies throughout the
United States to come work for them the
first film I worked on was a piece of
called The Bride of reanimator it's the
sequel to The reanimator which is a kind
of fun movie but the battery animators
but no matter the movie he loves making
masks
after a multi-day process of layering
plaster onto a sculpture and pouring
latex into a plaster mold a final shape
of the Mask is produced so now we're at
the beginning of the painting process
and we've got our blank latex piece here
and I mixed up a base color in acrylic
paint and I'm just going to start by
brushing it on with a big chip brush
just like this the colors you use and
the base colors you choose can be
anything under the sun it all depends on
the effect you want it to have on
viewers I want people to feel like this
is sort of a Whimsical almost H.R Puffin
stuff kind of character so for you young
kids that was a show on TV like 50 years
ago
then the next step I often do is
spattering so I take a very thin down
acrylic ink a cut down chip brush and I
start spattering the color on it the
point of the spattering is to make the
skin more convincing because skin of
almost any kind isn't just one flat
color and this helps to kind of simulate
that appearance it's really just a
matter of what I think is going to work
and I've painted so many things that
have become sort of second nature you
know what's going to work and what isn't
going to work
foreign
brush which is to a spray paint can
what a baseball bat is to a toothpick it
can do extremely fine Smiths of paint in
fact this particular airbrush couldn't
get down to a hair's wig
painting realistic characters means
layers and layers of color and blending
them as artfully as you can and that's
how you will result in in good looking
art
after painting in the eye details jorda
applies his own epoxy mixture to create
a natural wet look for the eyes and nose
as a final touch
so this is what a finished mask looks
like it's got the epoxy on the eyes and
the mouth and the nose the paint job is
finished you could always take it
further with hair work or more intricate
painting if you chose but for now this
is essentially how I do a mask this is
just one example of a finished mask
giordo can add infinite details to make
each mask unique so this is one of my
masks this one is meant to feel
considerably more realistic you can see
that there's a tremendous amount of
detail in it this is an example of mask
making taken to its most elaborate
conclusion most of the hair is glued on
in the back and then as you approach the
hairline it's punched in one by one with
a needle the sculpture isn't very
complicated but the hair makes it feel
very convincing this one is my
interpretation of the Creature from the
Black Lagoon this one also comes
complete with a translucent acrylic fin
that has to be cut and made separately
to attach the fin you have to go on
layer after layer of thickened rubber to
put it into the trunk off that I
sculpted into the mask and that way it's
totally part of the Mask
it's really cool to be well known among
the mass community at large but I think
the most gratifying thing is knowing
that I've influenced a generation of
mask makers who now are doing their own
stuff based on my work and there are a
lot of young up-and-comers who are quite
extraordinary way better than I was at
that age what's interesting to me is
that I've taken such a niche part of the
planet something that's really quite
absurd and turned it into my life's
passion it's endlessly fascinating to me
there's something about the idea of
coming up with a new life form and
breathing enough life into it that other
people believe it it's just the most
exciting thing in the world for me
um